foreign
foreign
foreign
what did I do you know I think it's it's
imperative absolutely imperative that
you know number one we give a quick
little disclaimer before we get into
this right the stream is not intended to
bash Hamza or attack Hamza that's not
what we're trying to do right but if you
guys know Hamza you know he's a pretty
unfiltered guy he has a second Channel
called Hamza unfiltered I don't even
think that was necessary because Hamza
himself is just always unfiltered and
that's something I admire and respect
about him he and I'm sure the other two
brothers can agree too he sparked um
something in US perhaps that many of us
men Do's recently when it comes to you
know physical self-improvement and stuff
like that so you know kudos to words do
but he did make a video about snico
called don't end up like sneako he gave
his two cents he said what was necessary
he spoke his truth so that's what we're
gonna do today
um and Hamza bro inshallah you watch
this and uh again we're doing this out
of love so about five months ago Hamza
got on a podcast right I'm sure you guys
want to remember this and uh let's just
quickly recap what that was if you guys
missed it I'm just gonna put it right up
and Rami asked him this question very
candidly on the show
where are you in terms of coming back to
Islam
seems like it's a uh
a process like it's not something I
could just like jump into I can't
imagine it's something that'll be quick
uh with everything you guys are saying
with for example praying and fasting and
telling my mind's automatically seeing
the progressive overload variation so
it's like instead of passing for the
entire month try it for a day or try it
with water but not with food and I'm
taking like the
um what what feels less friction for me
because it seems like a huge lifestyle
change and you guys know it when like we
were actually supposed to have a podcast
previously and it literally bailed
beforehand because like the pressure got
to me and I literally like I got
symptoms of being sick and like trauma
and everything like just Uprising
because as I said it in um I think it
was one of our messages in the group
chat like it's it's extremely painful to
have your views challenged there's a lot
of processing that needs to go on and I
need to spend like a couple of days with
my journal but one of the ideas that I
did get is after this conversation I'm
sure we'll speak and I'm going to
organize like a couple of days where I'm
just like I'm away for technology all
I've got just like a padded a piece of
paper and I'm just going to see what
comes out that's beautiful bro
alhamdulillah thank you man for sharing
that I had to ask bro like after this
call I'm like I need to know what this
guy's you know uh spiritually it's a
beautiful thing do you have a Quran in
your house
well I I just felt like we were talking
with him again yeah
bro although I feel honestly I feel so
bad look at him like you know Miss King
like it's like it's like looking at a
little brother to be honest man may
Allah got him I mean bro and and one
thing I wanted y'all to you know I want
to see if you guys agree with me in this
but he still genuinely seems very
sincere
and very genuine not like you know he's
out here trying to you know post Haram
or talk about XYZ that doesn't agree
with Islam out of any ill intent or
anything like that you know I believe
and I can't confirm this because someone
commented this but he's been on uh he
has the beef per se with snico lately
you know on the stream and sneako asked
him Point Blank bro are you Muslim and
he said no so I do want to say that I I
appreciate you know before you know
after me I appreciate that he's very
open about you know claiming that he's
not Muslim because it's generally not
from him you know we see a lot of
brothers today that claim to be Muslim
and sisters too may Allah protect us
from living a lifestyle that is directly
antithesis to Islam but at least he is
you know open enough and transparent
enough to say that no I'm not Muslim I
am curious and recently he's been you
know making some remarks about Islam
that's kind of what we want to react to
today in dissect but what do you guys
think about that
yeah I think he's sincere man I think
even in that first clip he was saying
just very common things like he's taking
the path of least friction the first
time he tried to come on he felt sick
you know this is just very very natural
things it's clearly a big deal to him
and I think that's actually something
that's beautiful because imagine if it
was something that just doesn't matter
to him it's like maybe I'll be Muslim
maybe not who cares it's not like that
and I think that's a very beautiful
thing and I think that shows real
sincerity and I didn't tell you guys
this but last night I just
I I was overcome by something I'm like I
I just need to message this guy so I
sent him a message and offered to send
the Quran that we actually offered to
send like a year ago
um and uh as of now nothing hamdullah
has kind of developed so on shot level
three but I I just want to get everybody
a Quran man yeah bro mahad writes is
live boys what do you think
uh I don't know
I don't know either bro I want to say
it's pre-recorded and we time travel but
then we're gonna have people on our case
being like brothers a Toronto joke or
whatever so
subhanallah okay let's go through some
of these comments
I mean I mean he's very sincere uh again
comes with a genuine guy may Allah guide
him
um Okay cool so first before we go into
the stream may Allah bless you all for
joining and tuning in please smash that
like button only takes a second the more
likes and comments that we get on this
the more gets promoted inshallah Hamza
can see this because again we have his
contact he has our contact we haven't
spoken in a while you know and we're
always here from Hamza even if you made
it this far bro off camera thing we're
always done even if you don't want to
record it if there's too much pressure
because I'll be honest with you I spoke
to Hamza before we did that podcast I
think you guys remember and that call
was pretty much almost as long as our
actual podcast bro and we covered a lot
so and again not gonna air anything and
and this is why we do this we don't
really care about just views and posting
anything we like posting things
obviously because you can you know
there's more Baraka you can Inspire more
people but at the end of the day homes
if you want to do it personally we can
do it too you know
someone who wish Hamza
sure bro I don't know
imagine Honda joins Islam Insha'Allah
insha Allah if Allah Wills
Yahoo brights how are you with one
alhamdulillah
get him on stream I'm the Bro opening by
bro you have my number inshallah we can
get you with the stream yard invite
inshallah
they were giving OG Labs uh
a break
yeah
let's see
ma rights I think Hamza is letting clout
get to his head Allah only Allah knows
and that's preventing him from
considering religion no I think see with
a lot of brothers and sisters there's a
lot of like you know childhood trauma
biases things that are holding them back
too so it's not always just
one-dimensional
yeah I think a lot of people fail to
realize too that we're all
on our own Journey
and
when someone's it's the time is the time
can't force someone
yeah also I think something else that
people forgot is that it's all in the
hands of Allah and many places in the
Quran Allah says that people will not
will for themselves to come to Islam
unless Allah Wills so yeah how it's
going to happen when it's going to
happen if it's gonna happen but if it
does it's only while they will love
Allah and listen it could be us it could
be we talk to him and something clicks
for him and Allah opens his heart he
accepts Islam on stream or it might be a
random guy in the street that he sees
and something just like you know hits
him deep down
sends shivers down his spine he's like I
need to I need to become Muslim and bro
it might not be anything it might not be
anything that anyone says it might just
be him doing what he's naturally doing
right now because what he's doing is
bringing him to his natural fitra and
when you get to the Natural fitra I was
talking to
uh
I was
I said I'll just let that pass actually
one thing I did want to touch on before
we go right into this
is
I get this question a lot and people are
always like okay you know Allah got who
he was right I'm sure we as Muslims
Muslims on this too you know it's up to
a lot of God it's not in our heads so
why does Allah just guide some people
and not guide other people
am I just not destined to be guided if
I'm not guided is it is it really my
fault if Allah guides we will
actually oh sorry oh you're asking you
know go ahead I was a rhetorical
Romney's already in Chef more bro
mashallah bless you bro you ready
um but I do want to hear what you have
to say about it but Allah you know Allah
swears by this and you know Allah says
that you know Allah doesn't misguide
anyone except those who are defiantly
disobedient so we gotta ask ourselves
too like if Allah guarantees that he
doesn't misguide anyone except those
that want to be misguided and those that
are definitely disobedient those that
can't put their ego and pride aside then
you gotta ask yourself is it really you
or is it Allah
yeah and if you think about it just kind
of as another just kind of further the
discussion if you think about it that's
the most logical thing to say so what
are you gonna say that Allah doesn't
cause people to be guided or Allah
doesn't cause people to be misguided
then you're kind of saying that there's
something that Allah doesn't have a
Grand overarching View and command over
so the most logical thing is that Allah
guides who he wills and he misguides or
leads astray or let's go astray who he
Wills because if you were to say that
Allah doesn't allow people to go uh you
know be misguided then you would say
that there's something people are doing
that Allah is not allowing and that
wouldn't make sense so it's the most
it's just the most logical thing for
Allah that he looks at people that say
to the heart if they're disobedient if
they're good or bad people good or bad
people I use those terms Loosely because
you know people are gonna think oh good
means that he's he's nice to people that
good can mean many different things bad
can be many different things but Allah
looks at these people determines the
state of their heart and just knows this
person is not going to be guy I did and
not because Allah is just like you know
he wants to but I'm not going to give it
to him it's because Allah has given him
signs he's rejected it he's just become
one of the kofar and he's just not going
to come to Islam and you're a real good
boys I'm gonna mute y'all because
remember I got the the crappy audio
interface so I say you know just for
stream yard whenever one of us speaks
um other people stay uh muted and then
whenever you speak you can just unmute
it so inshallah
um I'm done talking bro I'll put on the
the clip and I'm gonna mute myself uh
before we do we got a quick Super Chat
um from Brother Danielle one month ago
Allah got to meet you to your channel
may Allah bless you I was to continue
giving beneficial content I mean
um yeah so with that being said let's go
right into the clip I'm gonna pause it
like halfway through so we can you know
give our thoughts let's win the
we've got
afhzy what's your opinion of Islam as a
way of life I've made videos a while ago
saying I respect Islam I still do just
something that I've like I've had such a
hindrance like such a block to be able
to to consider I keep getting thoughts
to to buy like an English version of the
Quran and to read it hopefully it's like
a lot of the the
um the holy books are quite hard to read
even in English translation but if it
was easy enough to read and you'll
understand it I think that would be it
would be so much development there
so what do you guys think about that
first bit where he's saying some of the
Holy books are hard to read
some are like maybe he read the Bible or
something
wait let me
there we go
but um
masha'allah maybe maybe he read the
Bible but I think the Bible is extremely
difficult to read at times it's not
difficult to read it's just not like in
kind of a chronological order it has
like a ring composition that people
might think is a bit difficult to read
but when you read it looking for the
message purely and you're not looking
for any kind of chronology or anything
like that and you're just taking what
it's giving you it's very easy to read
well it's very easy to read especially
the clear record that I just pulled out
because this one is the is the the
Thematic version so you could see this
you can't read it but I'll read it for
you this verse or these verses
specifically it classifies it as dying
in a state of disbelief and this one
rejecting the truth and this one warning
against evil influence so actually
breaks it down for you it's in English
so obviously it's kind of a reduced
language compared to Arabic so you're
not going to get the full value but
you'll still get a beautiful beautiful
chunk of the value many people have read
this book even in English and they've
come to the conclusion that this has to
be from God it's like it's reading it's
like it's Allah speaking to me I think
Angel might have had a similar
experience but I'll let you talk about
that inshallah
so one thing I want to touch on bro and
people are wondering yo what is that
book all of you guys pulled up yes it is
the Quran but it is just as brother Rami
mentioned the clear Quran right which is
a very simplified translation of it
um maintains a message but it's very
clear just like its name intended and
it's very easy to understand
um so Insha'Allah you know brother Hamza
if you made it this far or you know you
want to reach out to us we'd love to get
you a copy of this and we can answer any
questions that you might come across and
show Allah along the way it's again not
complex it's not rocket science anything
like that
um before we resume the video on home
and just unmute you do you want to talk
on a little bit about your journey with
the Quran period after you accepted it
almost two years ago and why you think
this translation is a little bit clearer
for reverts
bro didn't we talk about this in the
podcast with them
I don't think we spoke about the clear
Quran specifically
oh okay well
first off bro Hamza if if you somehow
get this man like
come on bro we told you to send this
your location we'd send you a Quran like
it's
you talking about if you've been
thinking about reading it like bro send
send location bro we're not trying to
smash you we're trying to send you the
Quran bro
but in terms of my experience man with
the Quran like the first one that I read
was uh like super old English one
and like even even that being super
complicated and just very hard to grasp
that was still clear enough to where the
message was received
that's what's crazy that's what's really
crazy then I read the entire thing
second time I actually read it on my
phone they had an app it was better
English but not proper proper
that one was um a little better but
again like the message still
was going through like whatever Allah
Wills is gonna happen if if you're meant
to receive something
there's nothing in this world that will
stop that from coming to you
likewise if you're not meant to receive
something there's nothing in this world
that can make that happen make that come
to you you know you see what I'm saying
here but the third Quran that I read was
the clear quarter and this one that
we're telling you about right now and
let me tell you something bro this one
has been the best one because the
English is proper English it has
footnotes so it breaks things down and
gives you more context more information
to where you can really just get a true
grasp a true understanding of the Quran
at least as close as possible without
reading the actual Arabic Quran
um beautiful bro I appreciate you for
saying that bro I hope you saw that
comment Charizard with a drip
um we did get a question that I wanted
to address
um so I'm gonna quickly mute myself
around me do you want to address this
yeah so you can get the Quran at I think
the clearquran.com you can also get on
Amazon a few other sites uh would sell
it uh you can also go to the local
mosque a lot of them have them at least
down here in uh like the GTA area
um the many places you can get them from
inshallah it's not expensive I think
like maybe 13 to 20 Canadian dollars
you'll get it
include shipping probably
[Music]
um
sounds good and guys we are going to be
doing a live q a this Sunday 12 p.m
Eastern Standard time so please any
questions not related to the stream just
hold your horses until Sunday inshaallah
we'll go right back into this reaction
bro you can get a critical and for like
four four books yeah it's cheap bro yeah
it's cheap but it's Priceless bro if you
know what I mean or you can get it for
free if you go to the Masjid and just
ask them for one that's true that's true
but it's kind of like a basketball
player hoop bro I ain't even a Hooper
bro if you're looking for a Hooper his
brother Angel and Romney over here break
anyone's ankles bro Bismillah let's go
right back into it that's for me to look
into this it's so weird that I have such
a big block doing that I've had this
thought of okay just go into Instagram
and just just order a Quran to your
address and I just don't I just don't
because I don't know maybe it's like
facing responsibility it's facing you
know there's a level of fear involved
there's a level of like hesitation and I
just kind of push it off my mind then I
hear about Islam again and you know it
pops into my mind six months later a
year a year later month later or
something and you know I see the three
Muslims podcasts they're doing bits as
well
hmm
and that's why we are making this video
because there is no level of
self-improvement that anyone should have
today that does not include Islam
but what do you guys think about that
bro he said there's a block of these
feeling aside from the blog before I let
y'all go I just wanna
you know give my
I don't even want to do I I just want to
say like I I respect the fact that he's
asking for constructive criticism
that's that's a big thing you know to be
able to like ask for that usually we
want praise and we want people to agree
with us but to ask for constructive
criticism like
like I was that's real sincere bro
yeah I genuinely do think he is uh
sincere I generally do and even him
saying like that's it's very common I
think that maybe he doesn't realize that
it's very common for people to block
certain things out when they know in the
back of their head that it's going to
lead to some kind of tension or struggle
or hardship and they just want life to
be easy but and this is a question
genuine question for him and everyone
else you know
how masculine is it how manly is it to
put something off because you know
what's going to cause resistance
especially when you know that that that
thing might be the truth might be good
might be beneficial might be efficient
might be whatever it is you know why
would you want to take or choose to take
the easy route as opposed to the
difficult route if it's better isn't
that the whole point of the red pill
analogy that blue pill is like soft and
easy and it's a lie but at least it's
easy and red pills is the truth but it's
difficult to accept but at least you
have the truth it's not the whole like
red pill analogy so
um that's why people try to kind of Link
Islam and red pill like oh you know
they're they're one of the same because
Islam is the truth and Red Bull's
supposed to be the truth and we don't
use those analogies we don't care about
them we don't care about the red pill
philosophy if we it's obviously on
Islamic in a lot of places but just to
kind of resonate to their way of
thinking would it not be the most red
pill thing to take that route that you
know is probably most beneficial
see I like that you thought that bro and
quickly to recap this is this
pre-recorded yeah bro it's pre-recorded
that's how we're reacting to your live
stream I don't even know how that's
possible
um but I wanna I wanna quote Hamza and
ask him this question Hamza bro and I
don't I don't mean this to offend you
bro but isn't I I don't want you right
now you know I'm not gonna a lot of
people are commenting you know should I
still watch homes or should I stop
watching hamster listen I'm not I can't
give you a photo on that bro listen you
got to consult The Scholar for that but
what I will say when I used to watch him
he used to end every video with do the
hard work especially when you don't feel
like it so bro like take your own advice
and I'm saying this because I'm coming
from a place of love if there's a big
block that you feel and you want to do
something like intrinsically you know
this is something you should do but you
don't really feel like yeah you're
coming up with excuses a lot of time yes
it is what was like intrusive thoughts
there could be a myriad of reasons but
if you know it has to be done then
there's only one way forward bro
100 I feel like there's something else
I'm gonna say about it is
Allah bless you and Elevate you
immensely Allah I mean I mean Allah
oh what I'm gonna what I'm gonna say man
is like
Hamza I know that he knows
that as a man
our life is a struggle
like to be a man is a struggle
for everyone to be alive is a struggle
but
realistically for a man it's the biggest
struggle because of the
priorities or not priorities but the
responsibilities that are placed upon us
as men
so if you're running away from this
um the thing that I want to ask you bro
is like what else are you running away
from
you know so it's like
you said you you do the general thing a
lot you do the self-reflecting a lot
which is great bro that's that's amazing
stuff
so you should probably reflect on that
you're asking for some constructive
criticism
or reflect on the you know ask yourself
why why are you blocking yourself from
this and if you're blocking yourself
from this what else are you blocking
yourself from
that's very beautifully said and
subhanallah this is why I think he needs
to read the Quran because it will
address exactly what he is thinking or
feeling for example the end of Surah I
won't play it because last time we got
copyrighted
um so I'm just gonna read the last few
verses
um
so Allah
he says
kind of asking like so where where are
you going right so if thumbs up
theoretically is running from this where
is he running to
you know what I mean where is he going
and another kind of translation is is
like what path are you going to take
what path are you taking and then Allah
says uh that this is just a reminder for
the whole world it's not going to be
forced on you we're not going to be made
to follow it it's just a reminder and if
you want what's good for you then you
will follow it and Allah says after that
to whoever uh to whoever of you Wills to
take this straight away
basically do so but you cannot do it
except by the will of Allah the lord of
the world so it's very clearly put there
both for him and for us
basically where are you going if you
want what is good the straight path then
follow it it's just a reminder
right but you won't you won't will it
for yourself unless Allah Wills for him
and for us so if he wants to inshallah
if Allah Wills he will and if not at the
end of the day
where are you running to there are many
other words by the way all in there
inshallah something I want to add to
this bro
is uh
if for some reason
comes upload if you if you're worried
that
you think it's a huge life change and
and it's going to involve like a lot of
changes a lot of struggle and and it's
it's going to be difficult for you like
just remember there's this one part in
the Quran that literally like God is
speaking to you saying like that he
intends ease for you
not difficulty
so I was like yes it's not saying that
you'll never have difficulty because bro
like we're human
to live is to suffer to live is a
struggle but it's saying like God
intends ease for you so even when there
is hardship there is ease that comes
with that hardship and and God says
Allah says not just one ease but two
eases so if you can get past that
hardship then it's like you're rewarded
double two times the reward so
um again bro where you going are you
running I think it's phenomenal bro I
think this is color of the luck because
you said the two e the two rewards and
two times reward and I just wanted to
put you know this this super chat right
now because this is crazy bro the y'all
know what I'm getting to come on now the
the wonderful brother and sister that uh
donated the first uh 200 Super Chat we
got another 200 Super Chat two
um it's right here Nathan Allah gives
you the ultimate strength
while we're on the topic
the and we got that so it's and you know
at the end of the day may Allah bless
you for donating and supporting the
channel
um and I think it was It was kind of
ironic when Angel said that yeah it's
fun Allah uh while we're while we're
showing the topic um another one four
verses is I think Imam mentioned that
this is good for red pill people I think
it's good for Hamza as well because if
you think about it it really speaks I
think not just to everyone but the Hamza
in this particular situation Allah he
says
he swears by time and time not just time
as it was time that's running out right
so it's kind of tied with which like
where are you going you know what I mean
not linguistically not like a scholar is
not going to say that but I'm from my
point I'm tying it in with that where
are you going you know time Allah swears
by time that it's running out
he says mankind is in loss they're lost
right they're struggling they're
suffering they're lost
and they exalt each other to the truth
and they exalt each other to patients
right there
it's bro it's literally right there if
you want to be from those who are
successful at the end of this time
then believe do good deeds exalt
yourself and others too uh patience
exalted uh yourself and others too the
truth that's it bro don't run from the
Habibi accept it it's gonna make your
life better
it's going to make your life better you
think your life is good enough it's not
it is not your life will be made better
you'll be more content that fear you
have right now you'll be on the other
side of it you'll never feel that feel
that fear again imagine that never
feeling this fear again
bro it's amazing and I wanted to say
that Islam was revealed from what I know
about 23 years right it took 23 years
for the entire Quran to be revealed the
prophet saws from Allah God Almighty our
creator
um you know and long story short like
for a large portion of that time I don't
want to say majority I believe it's
around 13 years or so but for a large
portion of the time there was no Halal
and Haram in a lot of regards there was
no Sharia in the in the sense that
there's legal jurisprudence it was just
Coheed it was just adub like manners
etiquette and just belief in one God
everything that all the messages and
Prophets came too declare to us as
mankind so understand too that if you
are worried Hamza or once I become
Muslim not gonna fast every single
Ramadan now I gotta pray five times a
day yes you do but again look at look at
the way Allah has revealed Islam in the
first place 13 years give or take 13
years without all these things and even
even when you look at um and all that
stuff but just in in general about do's
and don'ts and then when you look at you
know even even understanding that this
this video the angel made on his
self-improvement channel too Shameless
plug
um and he talked about this thing about
self-improvement is gradual it's
gradualism so of course I'm not going to
talk about you know it's okay for you to
you know take forever and it's okay you
know it's not sinful for you to take
baby steps and that's not what I'm going
to say because it's not in my place to
say that but what I will say is when it
comes to taking on too much more it's
not accepted expected from you though
Allah doesn't expect Perfection Allah
expects progress nothing is perfect no
one's perfect only Allah is perfect so
at the end of the day you're not going
to become like a five-star perfect
Muslim with the beard and the thought
literally overnight like you don't even
have to do that I'm just saying that as
a joke but at the end of the day like
it's baby steps though but the first
step is to understand that okay if you
really put your ego aside and you see
that this is the truth accept it what
comes after that you know it's like a
ladder you just build and build and
build on top of that you're not supposed
to climb the whole ladder overnight you
know
yeah 100 and just on that note as well
it is true that when you accept Islam
you have to pray five times a day and
fast Ramadan and all these things that
people might see as a burden but once
you get to it I don't want to say a
certain level of practicing but once you
get to a certain level of God
Consciousness and a certain ideological
level understanding Islam as an ideology
you'll come to find that you're not
burdened with fasting you're blessed
with fasting it is a blessing fasting
Allah says in the Quran that we should
fast so that we can achieve taqwa which
is God Consciousness imagine living your
life being conscious of God
like what have either one of you had a
bad experience fasting Ramadan
Angel have you had a bad experience
passing Ramadan
no because it's a beautiful thing bro
ask any Muslim or at least any
practicing Muslim they love fasting
Ramadan we cannot wait we hope to die
during the month of Ramadan because it's
such a blessed time praying five times a
day bro it's not a burden it's a
blessing five times a day to sit down
clear your mind worship and connect with
Allah one on one who wouldn't want that
you don't have that in your life not I'm
just saying Hamza as an example as kind
of a variable but it could be anyone you
don't have that in your life why
wouldn't you want that it's a blessing
it's not a burden so why wouldn't you
want to have this blessing in your life
and furthermore let's say you accept
Islam and you should be praying well
let's say you're not at least you're a
Muslim it is better that you accept
Islam and that you're a Muslim who's at
least trying to get to that place where
they're praying five times a day and
fasting then just not accepting it at
all and someone put it in the comments
before I lost the comment now but they
Define what kaffir disbeliever is
kather comes from like kafara which is
burying something like Farmers when they
plant seeds and they're burying it
they're covering it up that's what a
catheter is
Iblis became a catheter not because he
disbelieves in God
shaytan Satan can't disbelieve in God he
knows God exists he's spoken to God
before he can't be like oh he no he
doesn't exist but he can reject God he
can reject God's message he can reject
what God orders him to do that makes him
a cafe so Hamza I think you know Islam
is the truth Habibi Habibi my brother
you know Islam is the truth and I know
you know it and you know you know it so
don't be a Catherine don't cover it up
if you know it's true just
we invite you
see there's there's one thing I wanted
to touch on bro and I remember I saw a
meme it was like even iblies is not an
atheist bro subhanallah
that's true man Allah
was there another clip we're gonna react
to from him yeah there is another clip
um because again he was very sincere in
the Stream so we're just going to play
that but before I do it I'm just air
computer
man in your journey in you know just shy
of two years have you felt any blocks
even after becoming a Muslim does it
just become perfect
you just say you believe and you're not
going to be tested
hmm
no you definitely gotta tested it's not
perfect
um
it's
like with anything you know for every
new level there's a new Devil
you heard that right
every new level is new Devil or new
Devils or something like that something
like that
always like no matter where you're going
no matter what you're moving in like
there's always going to be struggles
there's always going to be like new
things that you have to conquer
and I mean you could see that as like oh
I I have to do this or you can see it as
like a blessing like wow like I have the
opportunity
to do this I have the opportunity to go
into this new level and to conquer these
new things so like me becoming Muslim
it's like
did it come with problems
yeah there were some problems that came
with it but it was just it was a new
level it was something new to conquer
and now that I've conquered that
alhamdulillah like now I'm entering
another new level and then from there
it's just like it's again it's it's more
to conquer more to conquer
and uh like I sound like a like a tyrant
now like if I'm over here trying to lead
a rebellion
foreign
[Music]
for anyone new right now wondering oh
what did he even say what is the clip
I'll put it one more time right now uh
it's a short like 30 second clip anyway
um but before I do we got a Super Chat
around me if you don't mind reading that
subhanallah you guys don't know the
impact you have on the youth Allah
brought me to your channel a month ago
and since then I've got my Dean in order
also put some other brothers on keep
being real my Lord bless you all Habibi
Allah bless you as well
all good is from Allah we started the
stream with mentioning that no one's got
it except of Allah Wills uh so we thank
him and him alone alhamdulillah
[Music]
when we started this podcast bro
if we got even one person brought us
enough it's enough literally if we can
change one person's life by the will of
Allah then just come closer to Allah
we've done our job
so I'm going to play around
before you before you play this clip
before you play this clip let me finish
my point because I'm over here talking
about conquering and being a tyrant and
all this stuff and if I'm just watching
this he's like bro what the hell are you
saying listen this bro
Hamza I know you've been through stuff
in your life man
when you were a kid
you know from the the few things that I
heard in the videos that you said a few
things that you said you know we we're
talking on the podcast if I remember
correctly
um so I know you you have that that
trauma that you've been through
I know yourself reflect I know you
Journal I know you are doing the
self-improvement I know you want to be a
better person a better human being I
know you want to be a better man
um
and I know you want to ultimately be at
peace
and I remember you asked me in the
podcast you said what was the biggest
thing that I experienced
from you know become a Muslim I told you
it's peace bro because before Islam like
I was always looking for that peace
I went through trauma bro like I was
abused I was abused as a kid about my
entire childhood so like I was always
looking
to get away from that run away from
there with all these things trying to
distract myself and then when I found
myself Improvement I was like okay I can
actually hear from this so I was
constantly looking for ways to just get
better so I didn't feel the pain anymore
so I didn't feel that that just the
trauma and just holding me back and
making me act a certain way think a
certain way feel certain ways and all
this other stuff and it wasn't until I
became Muslim that I fully submitted
myself to the Creator and it sounds
weird so I won't say any much more than
that but it's not until I became Muslim
that I actually got the piece that I was
looking for and I know bro I know damn
well if you're on this journey
you've been through this stuff
yeah you're also looking for that piece
bro so
good running man
all right bro
just want to put them up just so we uh
show recognition bless you for that and
to this one too please start Discord
server and show Allah you guys say we
gotta do it now it's too late we gotta
start it up but for anyone that made it
here that missed what we covered so far
we did a little bit reacting to this
clip if you miss that we're not gonna
react it again so just rewind it later
about the clip that we did react to was
this one
we've got
afhzy what's your opinion of Islam as a
way of life I've made videos a while ago
saying I respect Islam I still do just
something that I've like I've had such a
hindrance like such a block to be able
to to consider I keep getting thoughts
to to buy like an English version of the
Quran and to read it hopefully it's like
a lot of the the
um the holy books are quite hard to read
even in English translation but if it
was easy enough to read and you'll
understand I think that would be it
would be so much development there for
me to look into this it's so weird that
I have such a big block doing that I've
had this thought of okay just go into
Instagram and just just order a Quran to
your address and I just don't I just
don't because I don't know maybe it's
like facing responsibility it's facing
you know there's a level of fear
involved there's a level of like
hesitation and I just kind of push it
off my mind then I hear about Islam
again and you know it pops into my mind
six months later a year a year later
month later or something and you know I
see the three Muslims podcast they're
doing bits as well
foreign
I'm confused didn't we just watch this
will be doing it I was saying because a
lot of people like oh what happened what
even happened
yeah
they could just rewind bro
I know bro but people are people are
lazy bro but anyway here's the clip that
I wanted to put up in a you know kind of
see what you guys have to say about that
to uh
you put your hands up like this and then
you basically stand like this with your
right hand fold it over your left a
right arm folded over your left and you
recite Surah Fatiha
can you teach me how to pray
of course boys bro we got you man we got
what did you right here bro on stream
we'll do it on stream bro we'll do it
live
um let's get rummy getting ready bro
you wanna kinda go over what prayer is
how it's not just the secular spiritual
it is a spiritual connection but it's
not just about you but it's actually
worship and do you want to then talk
about like how we as Muslims why we pray
and just go into that yeah so firstly I
want to say Salazar German speaking of
prayer is a Friday prayer we attend uh
every Friday it's obligatory for men
it's coming up soon so I'm gonna have to
bounce soon but to answer the question
Salah the word we use in Arabic when we
talk about oh teach me how to pray you
don't need someone to teach you how to
talk to God from your heart you're just
like hey God you know thank you for what
you've given me I appreciate it can you
give me this this and that so success in
my business could help you don't need
someone to teach you that what we're
referring to is something called Salah
Salah linguistically means connection
right and it's literally a connection
with God in a way and we have five of
these a day you know they say Muslims 25
times a day we have five obligatory
prayers a day you can pay more if you
want you could pray recommended prayers
and stuff but at least five obligations
so
Dua is the word we use for kind of
calling on God speaking to him in a kind
of uh more I would say Christian sense
of the word prayer we only have the word
prayer in English right but in in in
Islam in Arabic like I mentioned Salah
is more specific so what Salah is is
it's a dedicated prayer at a certain
time of the day for example is an hour
or so before Sunrise Maghrib is during
sunset Isha is later in the night and
then we have like asuru which is like
the midday prayer and which is like the
afternoon prayer and you have a certain
amount of time to pray these prayers and
it's a God that takes discipline and
it's it's beautiful so what you do is
you go but you say Allah which means it
is greater and the blessing and saying
that God has greater and not just the
greatest is you're not just a substance
that God is the greatest you're
establishing that anything that comes to
mind God is greater than that so you say
Allahu Akbar and you do something called
which you put your hands up like this
and then you basically stand like this
with your right hand fold it over your
left a right arm folded over your left
and you recite Surah Fatiha
which uh should I recite something for a
girlfriend
bro
I love it we edited my cough bro
listen bro
I know I know I know and Romney are both
laughing at the same thing I'm laughing
at bro remember when we were putting so
much effort into these goofy edits not
not that not clowning the edit or
anything because we're the one that told
him to edit it like this but we really
thought like all this energy that we
were putting in is what was actually
going to help us take off on YouTube but
we forgot about
just putting proper content out there
and just letting Allah take care of the
rest because it's not up to us anyway
bro my man out here like putting a zoom
in on every cough because everyone's too
cracked out of their dopamine and
subhanallah bro
and you recite Surah Fatiha
which uh should I recite something for a
gopher go for it all right
feel free to close your eyes and shut
off and help something but
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
that we recite every single time we pray
and it basically translates to praises
to God uh alhamdulillah praises to God I
mean the Lord of all of the worlds
everything that exists
is the one who is generally merciful to
all of his creation
in this life that's what Rahman is and
is the especially merciful who gives
Mercy to those who go there go out of
their way to seek it
Malik owner of the day of judgment
you alone we worship
and when we say you alone we worship
what we're also saying is you are the
only one I obey I don't make my own laws
I don't let the government I mean we
obey the law of the land but I don't let
them tell me what's morally right what's
morally wrong in my religion in my life
I that's God's job and I accept God
and you alone we ask for help we know
that we can ask people for help but it's
not going to come to us unless God will
us
keep us on the straight path
the path of those who you have favored
lust
um
not those who have earned your anger
or nor those who have went astray so you
could see that the first the first half
is praising God the second half is
asking God
so it's almost like a DOT like you're
praying like you're asking God for
things after you praise him and then the
rest of it you know we go we bow
basically to God we put our head on the
floor to God and when we have our head
on the floor we say Pandora which means
praises to God the most high so when our
highest point is at the lowest part of
the ground the world the ground the
lowest part
we say praises to God the most high
establishing that God is the highest and
compared to God we're basically nothing
we pray because God tells us to pray we
know that there is wisdom behind it we
know that there's benefits behind it we
know that it increases us spiritually it
blesses us mentally uh and even
physically certain positions that you
enter in are good for your uh you know
you're back in certain body parts even
like going in a bowing position it's you
know it strengthens the lugs in the back
and
uh although we do it for the sake of God
it does have those
I just want to say right off the bat
like hearing Romney recite just brings
me back to Canada bro
just bro I was praying all of us praying
together man bro I miss it I miss y'all
inshallah
okay and the next thing that I want to
say is that
I don't know if y'all feel the same way
but
if y'all just kind of like
forget that you're wearing certain
clothing right now and like we're
actually reacting to this
watching that stream
at least not the one with like all the
edits but like when you watch it and
there's like almost no edits and it's
just like all of us with Hamza like it
genuinely feels like we're actually
there again like we're actually talking
with him and we're all together like it
doesn't feel like this like it's just us
three right now
yeah bro I felt that bro and I think
that's because he has a very warm and
sincere presence he's not here with you
know coming sideways or mal and 10 or
anything like that
um so it is it is definitely someone
that is nice to have a conversation with
um but guys please smash that like
button if you made it this far let's get
to 500 likes we can do it and show Allah
we got to get home so to see this uh we
got to come in here brother fun writes
dear brother bless you you're doing
great work on this planet and we love
you love you for the sake of Allah too
bro happy
but on me oh no man anything you guys
want to say before we uh wrap this up
just again man he looked very sincere
masha'allah you know like
repeating the motions and all that um
all that stuff it's like he genuinely
wanted to learn so got into Islam one
thing I do want to say something that
came to mind is you know I have an
elective in sociology now
um so you know I'm going to talk a lot
about sociology and other things
sociologically speaking your environment
is is like everything it's so important
right that's obviously why in like
Christian majority countries
um you know they're the majority of
people are Christians so the majority of
people are born into Christianity even
if their their parents aren't Christian
that's what they're surrounded by right
so let me end up coming to after same
thing with Islam same thing with
secularism any political ideologies and
stuff I think if you were to spend like
a week with Muslims he'd be Muslim by
the end of the week but I I believe
truly because he's probably around
people who are not practicing Islam
product doesn't go to the most it's not
around Muslim Brothers I think he has a
girlfriend now as well you know it's
he's constantly bombarded with
distractions
right and what did Allah say in the
Quran he said what is this life or this
life is nothing but temporary delusional
enjoyment just distractions and enjoying
yourself until you basically run out of
time
so it's something else to be
you know aware of
here for that bro I think that's a
wonderful point to end it on unless
anything to say
oh yeah bro
that's a praise where there is no praise
to be do bro
um
I would actually recommend him
to talk to Faraz zahabi
because I've seen that he's actually
getting into the Muay Thai
so he not everyone if he wants to get
his Muay Thai and his MMA game on point
go ahead and talk to for us the hobby
he's in Canada he's in Montreal and then
when you're talking with him Insha'Allah
we can get you connected first you got
to send this location so we can send you
all the good stuff send Addy bro send
Daddy and then from there we can we can
get you connected all that stuff but bro
talk to Faraz the
HobbyTown point and bro he's Muslim like
and bro like the stuff that comes out
this dude's mind is insane bro he's just
he has a way of like just delivering uh
Islam and just the the philosophy and
just bringing it together so beautifully
I think you would actually benefit from
a very gravy Hamza if your son how to
see this
we did uh we did three episodes with
them and the first one we did with them
you guys can search up the three Muslims
for us the hobby it was on philosophy
and I I think that was the one episode
from all the ones we did that I myself
have replayed so many times bro because
there's so much benefit into it
um so may Allah bless him and anyone
that tuned in Romney do you have
anything to say to this question
Allah I mean and finding a hard to
reconcile Islam and signs this video by
Neil deGrasse Tyson explains it applies
to the Quran too I can't click that link
but maybe send it to my uh my Instagram
and my personal Instagram and shall like
and respond to you there about that
video particular
um there's no need for reconciliation of
Quran and science because if you think
about it firstly science doesn't come to
any absolute truths so you can't even
absolutely go against or for the Quran
secondly the Quran is not a book of
science right for example when Allah he
talks about
um you know the Quran being a burning
lamp and the the Moon being a light
um that's not supposed to be a
scientific uh finding or argument or
point it's just how it appears in the
sky you look up the sun looks like a
burning lamp you look at the Moon it
looks like a soft light it's just how we
see it right so to try and look at the
Quran and read it from a kind of
inductive manner oh let me test what
it's saying in a very literal uh
literary physical scientific manner well
you've already failed because that's not
what the Quran is even aiming to do in
most places in certain things like
embryology that's very clear it's
explaining and different ways it could
be interpreted you know what what is
supposed to be understood from these
verses and it could be scientific but to
try and look at the Quran from
scientific perspective fails in the two
ways that I mentioned so I hope that
helps also again just overall go to
Harm's resources about this I think you
have videos on it for the philosophy of
science and um why even
you know induction never gets you to
certain truths I think that well insha
Allah help you but I hope the answer
helped
all right with that being said guys who
made it before please smash that like
button subscribe share this video I
don't know if you can find Hamza he got
banned on Instagram bro uh take out band
from all socials sneako got banned from
Twitter bro they're coming for everyone
so uh if you can find a way to get this
to Hamza I'll be great insha Allah you
can send him a DM or comment on his new
video or something like that uh but with
that being said any other questions
insha Allah and myself will answer them
this Sunday day after tomorrow uh Sunday
at 12 pm Eastern Standard Time I think
it will be September 25th so inshallah I
will see you guys then uh one more thing
you're muted bro
I was just saying he just put the title
of the video okay okay got you okay
sounds good all right guys Rami do you
think Bismillah and with that being said
for tuning in Allah